hi I'm Tasha and I'm a beauty blogger
and makeup artist and I love a good brow
and I'm always searching for ways to get
good brows in a hurry
cuz I'm always in a hurry so if you want
to see how to get the perfect brow and
keep them watching so we all remember
the days of over plucking eyebrows my
eyebrows was so thin
thank God the thick brows are now in but
don't fear because no matter what your
browser like these steps are gonna make
sure that your brows are always on fleek
so for the first step especially if
you've got thinner eyebrows like me I'm
gonna put some thickness into the brow
so I'm going to be using the benefit
gimme brow and shade for so I'm just
gonna comb through the brows so as you
can see immediately adds thickness and
this is a perfect base to work on so I'm
just gonna do the other brow so now that
I've kind the brows I'm gonna start
shaping them so I'm going to be using my
Anastasi art Beverly Hills brow pencil
in dark brown and I love this pencil
because it has spoolie on the end so
great for us multitaskers so I'm just
gonna do feather strokes light motions
and then once you've got the bulk of
your pencil in you just want to use your
spoolie on the end to even the product
pot so you can already see a massive
difference between my two brows the next
step is to shape and define and I'm
going to be using two products to do
this benefit cosmetics brow in shade 4
and I'm going to be using the it's
cosmetics concealer by by under-eye so
I'm just going to start to really define
parts of the brow and want to be really
sharp so I mainly like to focus just on
the bottom that line to get that really
strong definition and sometimes I go on
the top so this step changes everything
this step is everything so if you feel
at this stage
you haven't got the shape that you want
don't fear because concealer is here so
I'm gonna start under the brow and I'm
gonna create my perfect shape don't
forget about the top does that need some
shaping too
I'm just gonna blend it out now so we
usually use a lighter concealer just
because it helps to give the brows a lot
more definition once you've blended it
out it just gives you a really nice
highlight and lastly but definitely not
least we're gonna be using a clear brow
gel just set those brows so that they
last all day I'm gonna be using my
Anastasio Beverly Hills clear brow gel I
love to use this in the front just
combing my hair up so they still look
sparse at the front like a natural brow
and then you just get more definition on
the outside these brows I'll go in
anywhere thanks for watching this video
hope you got some amazing tips and
tricks and your brows are gonna be
looking leaky in no time don't forget to
comment on this video and share with
your friends because everyone need some
help sometimes it subscribe to Glamour
UK's YouTube channel to see more videos
like this and don't forget I browse the
sisters